marie-guite dufay laquelle au milieu des
cendres
les restes d'une profession de foi de la
candidate socialiste
les noms aussi deux colistiers de julien
odoul élections régionales élections
départementales des centaines d'
enveloppe de propagande électorale ont
été brûlés sur ce chemin reculer une
découverte faite dimanche après-midi par
cet adjoint au maire du village de tard
en côte d'or il y en avait bien sûr 20
cm de haut sur tout le tour
donc on voyait qu'il y avait une grosse
quantité de documents en bourgogne comme
le montrent ces photos
les exemples de documents non livrés
sont innombrables
un coupable désigné adrexo l'entreprise
chargée avec la poste de la distribution
des plis dans un communiqué elle
reconnaît la situation
force est de constater que de nombreuses
difficultés ont été relevés sur
l'ensemble du territoire pour les
syndicats adrexo spécialiste de la
publicité n'était pas armé pour cette
mission c'est de la publicité qu'elle en
a dressé donc vous dire voilà une voix
tous les tons maintenant y en a pas on
n'est pas la distribution du courrier
comme effectivement une profession soit
c'est une une enveloppe par par un
lecteur un parent sont inscrits sur les
listes électorales
donc c'est un maillage que le secteur
connaît parfaitement
lui ne veut pas en rester là gilles
platret compte dans la région plus de
300 communes où la distribution a été
défaillante
il annonce un recours contre le
ministère de l'intérieur il ya une faute
de l'état donc je ne remets pas en cause
la victoire de madame buffet je les dis
dès le soir de l'élection j'en ai pris
acte
je les félicite et mais il me semble
qu'on ne peut pas aujourd'hui se dire
finalement tout ça doit passer par
pertes et profits c'est pas grave si
c'est grave et moi ce que je souhaite
c'est que la justice demain enjoignent à
l'état de lui même opérer cette
distribution à l'assemblée nationale cet
après midi gérald darmanin s'est dit
favorable à la reprise par l'état de la
distribution des plis